we have a voicemail number that number
is two
one nine to david p um
we are getting more and more people who
are contacting me saying david
i know i was a youtube subscriber and
youtube has unsubscribed me there is
some poor connection
that takes place during this voicemail
but that's the point that this caller is
trying to make take a listen
hey david um my name is jeremy a long
time listener
uh and long time subscriber um
i just wanted to let you know that um i
was watching your hair last night
everything was going
um fine on my end this morning
apparently i have been
unsubscribed from
it's not all in our um collected heads
it is actually happening i do not know
and i will not
um point fingers that if it is malicious
or just a bug um but
it just happened to me so thank you keep
up
the good work um and have a great day
yeah so listen here's the update i've
communicated that this is going on to
youtube
probably 20 or 25 times at this point
they finally acknowledge that this is
something that they've been hearing
but they are claiming number one that it
is a glitch but here's the really
interesting thing and this part doesn't
make sense to me youtube has said
when a glitch shows the button
as enabled again that lets you subscribe
when you're subscribed
you can't subscribe again the button is
different when you see the button that
says subscribe
most people would assume i'm not
actually subscribed youtube is claiming
that the glitch
shows the button as allowing them to
subscribe again
but that in reality youtube still
considers those users subscribed
they should still see our videos in
their home feed that's the problem that
i'm having because the viewers that are
contacting me saying i was unsubscribed
are even noticing that because they stop
seeing our videos in our in their feed
they stop getting the email
notifications for our videos so
i don't know what the truth is i i don't
think it's malicious
i think that it is clearly something
that's going on
in the youtube system that they've been
either unable or unwilling
to really drill down and figure out
what's going on and the explanation that
it is only a glitch in the button
does not strike me as the right
explanation because too many people are
saying the reason i looked into whether
i was subscribed or unsubscribed from
your channel
is that i was no longer getting your
videos in my home home feed
at all uh i don't know keep telling me
uh what your experience has been
if this has happened to you we've got a
great bonus show for you today the trump
administration is considering
uh unveiling a new health care plan in
september
uh the timing of that is relevant the
contents of the plan will of course be
very very relevant we will discuss that
trust in scientists is
rising according to a new poll i believe
that this is a good thing there are
people who don't we are going to talk
about that
on today's bonus show and we will also
talk about neil degrasse tyson
being slammed for an insensitive and
asinine tweet
following some of the events of this
weekend i won't say what events just to
maybe try to get
this video not to be demonetized on
youtube but some of the events of this
weekend
cause neil degrasse tyson to tweet and
he has been criticized
uh for those tweets uh as they they
being
insensitive and asinine two ways to get
access to this great bonus show that i'm
describing
become a member at www.joinedpakman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i look forward to
speaking to you on the bonus show or
otherwise on tomorrow's new broadcast
program